una gigantesca operación logística para
distribuir las primeras dosis de la
vacuna contra el hobbit 19 es el inicio
de un periodo intenso para los
trabajadores de la farmacéutica pfiezer
es aquí donde empacan millones de lotes
de la vacuna en hielo seco y almacenados
a menos 70 grados centígrados de
temperatura
lotes con las empresas de envíos ups y
fedex han sido encargadas de distribuir
a través del territorio estadounidense
un momento esperado por todo el planeta
y el que todos ellos se sienten
orgullosos de ser parte no haya tuvo el
privilegio hace años de volar un f-18 en
el cuerpo de marines de eeuu sirviendo
en la primera guerra del golfo y otras
cosas más pero ahora este es un tipo
diferente de misión estamos literalmente
en guerra contra esto contra esta
pandemia global y finalmente tener una
solución que literalmente ayudará a las
personas que salvará vidas es una
lección de humildad
los camiones llevan cajas con hasta 4
mil 725 dosis cada una y fai ser estima
que 20 aviones transportarán sus vacunas
diariamente por todo el país en twitter
el gobernador de california celebró este
día este es el principio del fin podemos
hacer esto usa mascarilla quédate en
casa tanto como sea posible aplastamos
esta curva y lleguemos a la meta
eeuu desde el país más afligido por la
pandemia con más de 16 millones de
infecciones registradas y cerca de
300.000 muertes
en total 64 millones de dosis están
disponibles la mitad se administrará de
inmediato y la otra mitad se reservará
para la segunda dosis tres semanas
después cerca de tres millones de
personas serán vacunadas en esta primera
ronda